>> Dave: IN THE PRESEASON GAME S
>> I MEAN THEY ARE DOUBLING ANDN
KARL-ANTHOHONET.OUR
REBOUNDS.
A COUPLE OF FOULS. WILL TRY FRO
AGAINST DENVER.
>> HE SAID EVERYONE WAS
>> Katy: TOO EASY. HAVE TO GET
TOGETHER ON THESE TURNOVE
THEN TOWNS WITH A FINISH.
MINNESOTA OFF FINISH LIKE A BIG
BOY.
THAT'S WHAT CHRIS FINCH WAS MAR.
GETTING
BACK IN TRANSITION.
SO DID
INTO WITH THIS ONE!
HERE
PUTS IT ON THE DECK.
AND,  ....  REMINISCENT
>> TOWNS, WORKING THE
OFFENSIVE GLASS.
HOW DIZONE.
>> STARTRTTHE WRIST.
>> MINNESOTA IN
THE LAST
>> Jim: EVERY SHOT'S A HARD SHOT
FOR MINNESOTA. HARD GOING FOR
PRINCE.
TOWNS BATTLES FOR ANOTHER
WOLVES WITH A FOUR-POINT
ADVANTAGE.
QUARTER.
ALL RIGHT, P.J.
WASHINGTON WILL SIT  JOSH HART
EXCU
PLAYING CATCH UP, THE LONG
REBOUND FOR PATRICK  YOU TAKE YR
TEAM.
SURGICALLY
OUR GOOD FRIEND -- HIS
LONGEVITY.
TOWNS WITH THE ATTACK THE NBA I.
THAT IS A THING OFCED
BY MINNESOTA COMING OUT
GET THAT SHOT OUT OF  FROM
TOWNS. 12, TAKEN
DIFFICULT SHOTSARE FINDING
FAST-BREAK OPPORTUNITIES .
>> Pete: IT'S INTERESTING, AS
VANDERBILT  AT KARL-ANTHONY TOWT
ELBOW TO GET SEPARATION.
>> Craig: THE ROCKETS ARE DOWN
EARLY IN THE SEASON. STEP BACK